are you already planting the seeds for
the next crossover event for if it's
Secret Wars or what like the space for
start to plant the seeds for whatever
we're gonna see because we obviously saw
Thanos the whole infinity saga the seeds
were planted way early on yes we debated
what we should announce today should we
announce four and five we've planned
them out we've got five years down the
road and I was like I think you got 11
projects in two years is plenty having
not mentioned anything for - two or
three years everybody is Charlie this is
gonna be my video all about spider-man 3
Marvel phase four phase 5 in the next
big Avengers movie because as Kevin
Feige implies it's all building towards
another really big event quote-unquote
but a lot of you are wondering why
there's no spider-man 3 on the Marvel
phase 4 schedule there's a really good
reason for that we'll break it all down
but we're still doing that Avengers end
game blu-ray giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best spider-man 3 theory on the
video so you all saw the big Marvel
phase 4 Comic Con panel Kevin Feige made
all these announcements he announced 10
big projects between movies and TV shows
during Marvel phase 4 over the span of
the next two years but he did not say
anything about the spider-man character
or spider-man crossing over with any of
the other characters or appearing on any
of the TV shows or anything about him
being in the next Avengers film so there
were a lot of people after the panel
that we're scratching their heads just
wondering is there no spider-man movie
gonna be happening in the next two years
is it gonna take three years to get to
the next film what's going on yes it's
true during all those interviews and
during the panel Kevin Feige never said
the words spider-man 3 once but in that
clip that I put at the beginning of this
a lot of you probably picked up the
Kevin Feige said they announced 11
projects in the next two years but there
are only 10 things on the Marvel phase 4
schedule so as you all probably
suspected that 11th secret project that
he maybe accidentally mentioned or maybe
he totally did it on purpose is Marvel's
spider-man 3 Sony has a very predictable
release schedule for their solo
spider-man films once every two years on
a fourth of July weekend you can set
your clocks by it but recently the
reason why people started to get nervous
around spider-man
is because there was a story going
around a few weeks ago about some very
questionable terms in the Marvel and
Sony sharing contract for the spider-man
character we know the terms were that
Marvel gets to use the character in five
of its films it gets to produce the solo
spider-man films Sony gets to keep all
the box-office profits they don't get
any of them merchandising though that's
of the toy sales the comic book sales
which usually ends up being more than
the actual box-office rule-of-thumb Star
Wars style is the earned way more money
on the toys than you do on the actual
movies the five films on the contract
were Captain America Civil War
spider-man homecoming Avengers infinity
war Avengers endgame in spider-man far
from home a lot of people just assume
that after that fifth movie their
contract was up they would have to
resign their sharing arrangement to
continue using the spider-man character
in the MCU
here's the thing though the reason why
everyone was triggered a couple weeks
ago is because someone was reporting a
rumor that the actual terms of the
contract were that if spider-man far
from home did not earn a billion dollars
then Marvel would not be able to make
spider-man three Sony would take the
character back and they would do
whatever they wanted to with them they
would make spider-man three or they
would try to put him in all the Tom
Hardy venom movies like we assume that
they're going to try to people ask Kevin
Feige at the premiere of spider-man far
from home will Sony eventually try to
crossover with the venom character and
he says yes they definitely plan to do
that at some point wasn't really a huge
shocker to hear him confirm that yes
eventually Sony does want to have a
spider-man vs. venom movie or spider-man
team-up movie with venom but if Marvel
lost the rights to the character after
far from home did that meant no
spider-man in Secret Wars Sony would
have to find some lame way of giving him
the symbiote even though I'm very
excited about them doing a spider-man
crossover in a maximum carnage movie for
whatever third venom movie that they
wind up doing is that trilogy builds up
to its own infinity war level event of
course it would probably be maximum
carnage but whether or not you believe
the rumor about the billion-dollar
contract something really really cool
happened just last week during Comic Con
as you all probably saw spider-man far
from home made over a billion dollars at
the box office so whether or not you
believe that billion dollar stipulation
it doesn't matter because the movie
earned over a billion dollars me
that marvel would have the rights to
make spider-man 3 they would still need
to resign their sharing arrangement
which they probably already done they
all probably expected spider-man far
from home to earn over a billion dollars
so a lot of this was probably decided on
a long time ago they just couldn't make
it public because it was all secret we
had to wait till it actually made a
billion dollars to say anything about it
but if everything's good you ask why
isn't it on the schedule for Marvel
phase 4 if it's gonna be happening
summer 2021 the real reason why Kevin
Feige hasn't said anything about it and
the reason it's not on that schedule is
mostly because Sony still technically
owns the rights to the character even
though Marvel makes all the spider-man
movies Sony releases them in theaters so
it will be Sony to make the spider-man 3
announcement saying we're working on it
it's coming out 4th of July weekend
2021 and the other really good news is
because Kevin Feige and Amy Pascal the
director were talking about spider-man 3
separately at the far from home premiere
we already know a lot of details about
what they planned for that film so quick
top 5 spider-man 3 details rundown
number 5 spider-man 3 will take place
during Marvel phase 4 and because of the
original idea of the movies following
him through high school Harry Potter
style in two years when the movie comes
out he would be in his last year of high
school getting ready to graduate the
movies have been about him maturing from
a more spider boy to a fully actualized
Spider Man science bro self-sufficient
making his own suits even if he's using
Iron Man technology usually high school
graduation is around the time where most
kids are viewed by the law as adults
because you're 17 18 years old because
of that shitstorm of the post-credits
scene thank you very much Jay jonah
Jameson and Mysterio for outing him as
spider-man he now has very adult
problems to deal with in that third film
for you ask who the main villain is
going to be at the premiere the director
was saying that he wanted to use Kraven
the hunter he's one of the few core
spider-man villains and og sinister six
villains that they haven't done in any
spider-man movie yet and way back during
spider-man homecoming days Kevin Feige
and Amy Pascal said the big thing with
all their new Tom Hollands spider-man
films is that the whole idea was that
they would do stories that have never
been done before on screen and
characters that we've never seen before
3 you ask what about
sinister six team up wouldn't that be
the coolest way to end an MCU spider-man
trilogy and I said yes of course it
would be awesome to see sinister six it
definitely seems like they have plans
for that at some point they have enough
characters to build themselves a
sinister six between vulture all the
spider-man homecoming villains that are
still alive and all the people that they
would introduce in the next film but at
the rate they're actually pacing these
solo spider-man movies out it still
feels like they're going at a snail's
pace like spider-man 3 is going to be a
movie with one main villain in a couple
of Easter eggs maybe a post-credits
scene setting up sinister six at the end
for whatever next spider-man trilogy
that they do I will find a cure I will
number two the next trilogy what are you
talking about Tom Hollands current
contract right now only goes through
spider-man three he said a long time ago
that he wants to stick around and
continue playing the character for a
long long time and because they started
when Tom Horne was a little kid he'll
still be in his 30s if he sticks around
for another ten years
that's still a very young version of
adult spider-man there were a lot of
reports on the internet a while ago that
Sony had plans for nine more spider-man
films
I think that's an exaggeration but yes
they definitely want an adult spider-man
trilogy after they finished this high
school trilogy imagine a trilogy of
movies with spider-man working his way
through college at Empire State
University in number one as you all
probably wondered Jay jonah Jameson is
going to come back in a bigger way for
spider-man 3
they didn't say whether he would be a
main antagonist but he will be coming
back and he will have more scenes than
he had in spider-man far from home his
crusade to destroy Peter Parker in
spider-man's life as much as possible is
only beginning if you didn't see it
there was a really cool clip of Sam
Raimi his reaction to that post-credit
scene he says something really
interesting during this - do you know
this was happening in advance for you
given a heads-up yes I was um JK called
me
I guess I'm spoiling it now so jakey
called me and said hey they're tracking
me about reprising my role what do you
think I said with all my greatest
blessings because I love spider-man and
I love JK knees I'd love to see more of
them so you take the pictures I'll make
up the headlines okay alright that okay
with you yes sir so if what wasn't clear
Sam Raimi has been a big fan of Tom
Hollands spider-man film and all the
things that they've done with the new
spider-man films but I love the idea
that JK Simmons called him up to ask for
his blessing in reprising the character
even though technically it's a slightly
different version of Jay jonah Jameson
also thinking about the future you
probably saw Amy Pascal teasing Sony who
had sort of workshopping ideas for a
live-action spider-man into the spider
burst movie at some point but that would
be separate I don't know that that would
be a Marvel spider-man film that would
probably be on Sony to do something like
that themselves whatever your fantasy
pic of a spider-man movie is they
probably have plans to do it at some
point
with Tom Hollands character and I know a
lot of you are thinking about that clip
with Kevin Feige at the beginning of the
video wait a minute he's talking about
Avengers 5 what's going on with that I
will do a new Avengers 5 Marvel phase 5
video because that's when the next
Avengers movie is going to happen also
really good venom news it seems like Tom
Hardy recently confirmed Andy Serkis
would be directing the venom versus
carnage sequel this fall but Sony will
probably make an announcement about that
sometime soon congratulations to Sean
McVeigh here the giveaway winner from my
last big Marvel video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details
everybody click here for my Thor for
love and thunder teaser video and click
here for my Schanke Iron Man teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]